Frank I so loved the New York Daily News
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
how you doing Frank well rich you just
said something that's interesting I
think most people watching the game
didn't know there was a rule yeah just
like we didn't know why can't you review
LeBron James blocking Victor Oladipo
shot in the final seconds which had they
reviewed it would have been goaltending
or Kevin Love elbowing demar derozan
in the face and that would have been a
flagrant foul and that could have
changed the outcome of Game one on
stools the belief what the NBA needs to
do adopt kind of an NFL way of doing
things maybe give each team one
challenge in the first half two
challenges in the second half and just
be done with it well what the NFL does
though Frank is it does allow last two
minutes they just remove all the
challenges it all comes from the home
office now and that's where it would
have been last night the the difference
between the NFL and the NBA here is that
yes you can you can let's let's review
whether somebody's in the restricted
area or not you could see feet placement
that that makes sense but when you open
up replay why are we now deciding
whether it was a block or not when
that's a judgment call that that would
basically like let's make holding in the
NFL open for interpretation when you
open it up to see if somebody was in
bounds or not
you're 100% right I think you know it's
so subjective and you mentioned on the
call how you know Jeff Van Gundy thought
it was a charge
Steve daddy are you know a very
respected referee who now works for ABC
and ESPN keeping such a charge but yet
Kenny Mauer and Tony Brothers and Tony
Brothers was the one who originally was
going to call a blocking foul they're
the ones that and obviously Kenny Mauer
felt it was a charge but when they
reviewed it they changed it to apply I
just don't like it cuz you know to me
you know how often do you really see
that you know at all during the regular
season much less the playoffs and here
it is you know the last minute of Game
one of the NBA Finals so here's the NBA
again on an unbelievable night just in
terms of some of the performances LeBron
step Curry's it's the drama of the game
and as it usually is with the NBA a lot
of the focus is on one or two calls and
on the referees yeah I just the the fact
that replay came into bearing like that
I mean that talked about a Pandora's box
and I'm seeing mark
been tweeting about it all day putting
up links to articles to moments in
previous games where no call is made or
both calls they say it's a charge and a
block and let's just jump ball it from
there is is that what should have been
done last night I mean what do you think
should have been done last night Frank
and that has happened before that once
again I think you know this physical
contact on just about every play there
were a couple you know LeBron James got
fouled on that play when Looney grabbed
his arm as he was driving and the
referees didn't see anything I just
think the way to take care of it give
each team two challenges for example
let's say klay Thompson has four fouls
in the third quarter he picks up his
fifth with a minute to go in the third
maybe that's when you would use it
because you don't think that he
committed the foul you want to keep him
in the game it would bring a little bit
more strategy into it I think it would
cut down on a lot of these reviews it's
like you said when I watch these games
when Victor Oladipo gets blocked at the
basket in Game five which would have put
the Indiana Pacers ahead in the five
seconds that's a season changing type of
player right there I didn't realize that
the only way that can be reviewed is
that they originally call goaltending so
why doesn't the rep just call
goaltending to cover himself stop play
and let's see what happened and let's
actually see what happened on the play
so I don't understand why there
sometimes you can review things other
times you can't and I think it makes it
confusing to probably a lot of people
who are watching these games who don't
watch as much NBA basketball as you and
I do Frank I sold the New York Daily
News here and the Rich Eisen show that
said there was another moment the game
that decided quite a bit asked the poll
question a Frank Isola Christopher yeah
Frank which was the more game-changing
moment last night the charge block
reversal on the bran or the jr. Smith
brainfart juniors gonna be the more
memorable one but you know if the Cavs
keep the ball there they're up to with
the ball 36 seconds to go so even if
they worked the clock down and miss it's
still up to the Warriors to have to make
a shot yeah what jr. did there you know
the games still go into overtime and I
can't believe that he sat there after
the game and tried to say that he he
thought
you know that he knew that the game was
tied you know four years ago with the
next we're a at a game in Houston the
Knicks were the game was tied
he took a three when the Knicks had
possession of the ball 20 seconds to go
shot clock turned off he took the three
missed it after the game he admitted I
thought we were down by two so four
years ago he did the same thing and he
did admit to not knowing the score maybe
because of how big of a moment this is
he doesn't want this to you know be
linked to him but I don't know I think
that's gonna be a tough one to get away
from why would you grab why would you
grab the rebound with 4.5 seconds to go
when he officially grabbed the rebound
in dribble to midcourt
you're trying to kill the clock there
that's upsetting up I get it you grab
the rebound you dribbled into the corner
because you're trying to create space
for yourself because Kevin Durant would
have been contesting a shot right at the
rim alright you want to want to sell me
that one
maybe I'll bite but you can't dribble
the ball to midcourt and claim that you
knew that the game was tied that makes
no sense whatsoever
it makes no sense whatsoever you are
correct but then this is a another
junior Smith moment that you're pointing
out and it's similar to the one where he
you know mentally checked out of the
game and then thought he should be
physically checking out of the game and
the guy who's guarding got an easy two
ba two points the question is how do
they how do the Cavs come back from this
obviously they have opportunities it is
just one game but this was and this was
it they had it right there Frank yeah
think about it
LeBron scored two times in the final
minute of regulation which gave
criminally so twice LeBron provided go
ahead basket and they still couldn't
hang on in win it and I've never seen
those guys as angry and disappointed I
mean there that was LeBron like they've
never seen him before how angry and
upset he was he knows that they've let
this one get away from him
here's the thing like this guy is
playing it's such an absurd level like I
think he's capable of if it's a seven
game series that's probably the only way
Cleveland could win
he's probably capable of five more of
these games he always has kind of like
one really bad game Game five against
Boston was a really bad game 10 the
supporting cast do enough now
tonight you have George Hill missing the
free throw which would have given the
league and then the jr. fit play and you
could see the look on the bronze face as
he's looking at Junior Smith but you
also it's like the weight of everything
it's like I need these guys every once
in a while to come through it's like
just can't always be me now granted they
did come through in the fourth quarter
of Game seven against Boston but it's
gonna be difficult because Golden State
has a lot of weapons and we'll see what
happens Sunday I'm good I'm getting to
the points on Eric's where um I'm not
gonna underestimate LeBron James I think
he's capable of anything at this point
well certainly a fig with Dollaz out and
then the Warriors just don't look right
right now for whatever reason so I agree
with you that said Frank I saw what the
Daily News a couple more minutes with
him that let's let's dive back into Nick
history again to try and provide some
perspective now Kevin Love stepping even
a toe out on the floor last night Frank
when there was the Tristan Thompson
draymond Green and Shaun Livingston etc
etc that was going on on the floor do
you think he might be suspended based on
the history that we've seen the inner
NBA doesn't care whether it's the
playoffs are not like the Knicks heat
series from back in the day yeah and the
obviously the Phoenix Suns San Antonio
Spurs when they're that Mariano Meyer
left the bench it used to be letter of
the law I don't think it's that way if
you go back to I believe it was April
23rd it was a Oklahoma City Utah game
something happened on the court Russell
Westbrook was about to check in and he
walked on the court and he confronted
Rudy Gobert so there's been like a bit
of a skirmish and not only the Westbrook
leave the bench he actually joined like
he confronted Rudy Gobert now the NBA
said well no he was about to check in so
it's different so something tells me
that they're not going to suspend the
two players I think it seems like Adam
Silver's a little more lenient than
David Stern used to be but Justin
Thompson was totally out of line ders
you gotta leave the court there now so
that draymond Green is a knucklehead you
already picked up one technical foul on
the game we know your history from a
couple of years ago why are you taunting
the player right there you've already
won the battle you've won the war just
like pack it in you got what you wanted
and Tristan Thompson if anybody gets
suspended I think it could be Kristin
Thompson
more so than it would be Kevin Love but
it was a really ugly and
good game yeah it was what a crazy night
right Frank I mean that was a nutty I
mean that that is an unpredictable game
one is we could have expected from
warriors cabs for yeah and I think also
it's just so great to the NBA the NBA
you know we talked about this before
it's a drama league you know so Bryan
Colangelo stuff that he's always stuck
off the court but even on the court last
night
you know guys were playing at a high
level but there was a lot of wacky
things that were happening and you
mentioned the Warriors not looking right
to me it's Kevin Durant somebody said to
me Kevin Durant looks like LeBron did
when he was in Miami and they lost that
year to Dallas like to me he's just not
taking over like you think you would I
felt in Game seven against Houston it
was Steph Curry I really thought why say
that Steph Curry basket was just kind of
getting lost in the shuffle after they
fell behind he drives he gets hit by
Kevin Love he converts deep the shot
that he makes the free throw
I thought that was a huge play Steph
Curry was terrific last night so in the
minute I have left with you Frank what
do you think does happen with the
Colangelo situation in Philadelphia how
do you think it's gonna play out you
know what it sounds like he's probably
gonna be out of a job my only thing is
you know all these GM's leaking stuff
all the time
I mean didn't you think that the San
Antonio Spurs were kind of leaking out
stuff about Kawhi Leonard all throughout
the season I don't remember anybody
wanting an investigation launched I
guess it's just the way that it's
happened and I don't know if it's in it
but it it probably is his life if I you
know if I had to guess I feel badly for
him because I think you know when family
members get involved I have a little
more compassion for people when it comes
to something like that but it looks like
to me with you know how it works Richard
it just seems like this the momentum is
is rolling towards him not being out of
a job Frank appreciate the time always
love our chats always thanks keep up the
good work right back at you that's Frank
I so love the New York Daily News
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience